let me throw it to you gilbert cool
you're at a restaurant by yourself
and you see a friend of yours let's call
him
tommy g tommy and tommy tommy g goes
hey dude you're eating by yourself hey
can i sit with you
would you say yeah yeah sure sit down
okay what if tommy g
had a friend my friend billy's here
billy sits down
and billy has nice guy you know pretty
cool guy right
but he had a tumor right
the size of another human head dripping
from his head
oh is it oozing yeah no it's not oozing
it's just a tumor that's just like
hanging from his head and you're eating
with him
would you be like and the tumor's like
you know you're eating
you're a mexican restaurant yeah and
it's like his tumor is like kind of
dunking
it's just dipping into the salsa oh i
just go would you ever do you
would you completely ignore the two
if he sat down i go who's your friend
yeah
you make a joke immediately oh oh
oh oh i see what you're saying you look
at you oh that's very good i see the
friend i see bill oh hey billy nice to
meet you
with my i would even put my hand out to
the tumor and try to shake it
like for me i don't want to deal with
like yeah because they know i see it
it's like i told you my friend with the
three fingers on his hand yeah i will
purposely shake his hand yeah
squeeze it yeah like search for he knows
that i know i'm feeling it
i don't want to deal with the
awkwardness later see what i would do is
different i would do the opposite
right i would be i would try because i
don't want him to hurt his feelings
mental gymnastics i know but if his
tumor was dipping into the
salsa i would take a chip and still eat
the salsa
and pretend it didn't happen you would
probably even go pascal
[Laughter]
more flavor yeah yeah yeah i don't i
think i would completely ignore it why
do you ignore those things
like because i don't want to hurt his
feelings i'm going to go hey nice tumor
you don't think it's condescending nice
tumor friend i mean he would laugh you
were like hey nice tumor
yeah that'd be funny yeah like kalala do
you ignore
anything like say someone has not a
pimple but like like a deformity
which we all can see do you avoid ever
bringing it up
or even asking about it or do you just
go on
if it's very like upfront in your face
like bobby describe
i i choose my moments wisely with people
i also am really like sensitive to that
stuff
um so yeah i choose my moments wisely
like there would not there be nothing
i've never felt awkward around people
with deformities just because yeah i
choose my moments it's like if they
if they start the conversation if they
want to open up that's fine
if not they're a regular human being if
it doesn't get in the way of our actual
conversation like
what's it to me that he looks different
than me or if it doesn't get in the way
it doesn't get in the way then who cares
i don't give a [ __ ] now if it's getting
into my salsa
yeah then i'd be like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa you crossed the line
no no no no
i would be like i would be like yo like
you're you're
i would i would probably try to take a
napkin to his tumor and be like you're
getting it wet
yeah yeah yeah you're getting yourself
wet yeah my po here's my point of view
if i have a tumor on my head and i meet
anybody for the first time
i addressed the tumor i don't think you
have to address it too we all see it
no but to make it not i have a tumor no
not
attack no no whoa whoa whoa
no no no no no i wouldn't be like that
i'd just be like
if i'm i have a tumor face i have a
friend named tommy g
tommy g is like hey i'm gonna sit next
to my friend gilbert right when i sit at
the table
before you i even shake gilbert's heads
i'm gonna be like sorry about the tumor
it might yeah it's so big it might you
know i mean following the salsa
fall in the salsa so that it opens up
the conversation for you to go
to say things about it yeah but why does
it have why does he have to wear it
bear the emotional burden of your
discomfort around him
because i just want to because like i
don't have to like if something is wrong
with me and let's say like
i'm missing like an arm or whatever why
do i have to explain myself just so
you're not com
not you're on not uncomfortable where
it's like grow up
it's [ __ ] we're all different bodied
like it it's fine
[ __ ] happens we're there are a lot of
different [ __ ]
possibilities for how we can look it's
fine an arm is different than a tumor by
the way
no but what i'm saying right humor is
something that you would have to address
i think
well no that's i if it happened to me i
don't feel like i have to keep
explaining to everybody around like what
it is can you just get over the fact
that yeah something's
possibly growing on my face and that
it's different from yours and then just
like
move on yeah i will say anyone i've
encountered is usually being
in comedy so they're the ones that
always bring it up
but i feel like that's a way to like
deflect too like i feel like they do
that because
of course you know they're worried that
people are uncomfortable around them but
if i had that [ __ ] i'd be like
sit in your discomfort i'm not even
going to explain to you what this [ __ ]
is
so at no point so at no point she does
have a point when it falls
salsa she goes whoa whoa whoa that's
true yeah i'd be like let me
wipe your tumor for you now it's wet
then do you order another salsa i'd call
the waiter or do you leave that out
that's it that's that's interesting
that's interesting i'll answer your
question
yeah look if it's not an unhygienic
thing
yeah no i'd eat it because guess what
they're [ __ ] people bare-handed
making your food anyways it's the same
as [ __ ] the meat on his tumor and the
meat on their hands it's
fine how rude it would be if you go
waiter
can i get a different sauce first of all
i can hear you whispering dude yeah my
tumor can hear you whispering
yeah what kind of tumor are we talking
about it's like an elephant trunk
yeah that's what i'm saying like like
elephantitis yeah i've seen that on like
you know
in that the show that i love the body
bizarre right bizarre
i saw a lady with hands right that were
like
the size of um you know i mean
a [ __ ] ottoman like they were
gigantic hands right
so it's like if i have those kind of
hands
and i meet somebody you mean do i shake
it or do i go hey man you can just shake
the finger
all right well that's so specific no
because it's so big like i would have to
because if you put your hand it'll be
weird so i just think hey dude i don't
have big hands but just
i'm shaking your hand but just shake the
[ __ ] the fingernails i think you
should offer the hand anyways and then
wait for the move if they're not
comfortable shaking your hand they're
going to be like dude my hands are too
big so
they're too heavy i can't shake it
because that's what i do like when
people yeah
he looks like you're the idiot dude my
hand you know how big my hand is yeah
yeah yeah oh
man then it's on you then it's fine
because like sometimes people do that
like they
they extend their hands and i'm like i'm
sorry i can't shake your hand because i
have oh
yeah you know i have wet fish for hands
imagine putting up your big hand and
then them
not shaking it and then it just starts
getting heavy and you just hold it there
yeah
[ __ ] shake it shake it
what are these scenarios i i just love
these scenarios
because these are things that i think
about social things i think about at
night it could happen the thing is it
could happen yeah like when i see body
bazaar
i think about like what it would be like
to either be them
or what it would be like you know to be
out in
in the world socially you know and what
are the like
what are the social you know norms and
things that you do yeah yeah i always
think that like their experiences
are probably so different than yours and
probably present a lot of challenges so
like why be a dick and just like
stop making their life more difficult
and just treat them like you would
anybody else
yeah yeah i would probably
you know if i had something like that i
would just play it up
that's our personality though yeah like
you know i saw
one time i saw on body bizarre you know
someone that has a skin
very skin condition where they don't
have a layer of skin so it's like red
you know and they can't be on the sun
that was a really sad one yeah if i had
that i would probably wear
constantly like a freddy krueger sweater
so you'd play it up and play it up yeah
and have the hand you know
the knife hand yeah yeah and just play
it up and get in
you know a cheap halloween costume yeah
[ __ ] you
save money you guys are awful
it is terrible yeah you know we should
you know
and i think when i watch a show like
what people ask me why do you watch
shows like that
and um i think gratitude
oh but by the way i think i need glasses
you feel like you can't see he's he's
been
i i've been blind he's been blind guys
for a while he's just
been under the diagnosis from what
you've seen the past i think that he
just needs glasses he can't see
well he hasn't since i've known him he
hasn't been able to read
from a certain distance where i'm like
how can you not read that